we want to bring in Florida Governor Ron
de Santos he is joining us now in an
update on the situation with those two
cruise ships set to dock in South
Florida governor thank you for being
here what is your announcement right now
on what is gonna happen with those
passengers with so many of them having
fallen ill yes sir well I think we have
a plan the county Broward County where
the port is working with the
stakeholders the cruise lines as well as
the Coast Guard to be able to bring both
of those ships in but do it in a way
that's gonna be safe for the people of
Florida there are a number of Floridians
on the Zaandam so obviously you know we
want to welcome them back and get them
to be safe there's also and I think
there's been a little confusion about
some of this there's probably another
two dozen ships that are out there and
some of them want to come to Florida
none of them have American citizens
they're all foreign crude and you know
we've been very concerned about that the
Coast Guard's been concerned about it
so this ship the zaandam then the Coral
Princess we think we have a plan to do
that to make it to make it safe and to
get our folks home but you know some of
these other ships out there I think will
be a big big problem because it really
has no connection to Florida or to the
American people as you know governor the
Holland America CEO has been pleading
for help on bringing these ships in and
getting some of those passengers who
need critical help immediately he said
it's a humanitarian situation he's
calling for compassion and reason what
are you going to do with some of those
critically ill passengers that are on
board those ships yeah so we worked with
the local hospitals and I know we have
one hospital that is able to take some
of the critically ill they have the
capacity to do that and I think that
that can be done and I think that the
numbers are such that it's not
necessarily gonna overwhelm as you know
one of the main issues with this
pandemic is you know people are gonna
get infected it's a respiratory disease
it's just the way it happens it spreads
but you know we want that spread to
happen slower so that the system doesn't
get overwhelmed the medical system we
worked very hard in Florida I think we
have more availability of beds than
we've had in quite some time and that's
been a lot of diligence the
are working hard we've done some
executive orders to do that so we just
were preparing we've prepared for this
surge and we want to make sure that that
the beds are available for the
Floridians who need it but on on the
zaandam those folks will get into a
hospital in South Florida as soon as
this agreement is reached and you know
it is the humanitarian thing to do but
this is a pair of cruise ships that
we're talking about that is going to be
coming in to dock a short time from now
carrying more than 200 guests and crew
with flu-like symptoms although only
eight it tested positive according to
the latest reports in front of me
obviously many of those other passengers
could be walking around with the corona
virus are you going to allow those
passengers to get off the ships and will
they be tested it's so right so the
agreement is that that hopefully will be
announced today all this is going to be
controlled so for example the foreign
nationals you know they are going to be
bused to the airport but they are not
going to go inside the airport
there you go directly to a plane flying
somewhere from Canada by some other
countries and do it that way so it's all
gonna be done in ways that are not going
to expose the people of Florida to any
of the illnesses that may be on there
there's been a lot of of things that are
being discussed to do that and obviously
you know you got to be safe when you're
when you're doing this stuff and so so I
think that they found a way to thread
that needle and and if they and if they
did and that that ends up the deal gets
finalized and then I think everyone will
be fine but yeah we obviously would be
very concerned with a ship where this
illness is circulating to just basically
release people into the general public I
mean that would be totally contrary to
everything else that we're trying to do
for public health not only in Florida
but throughout the country right now
so governor I'm not exactly sure what
you just said about putting them on a
plane after they get off the ship and
going to Canada are you talking about
their 880 guests on the Rotterdam 583
crew onboard 311 of them are
learning's I'm just telling you what the
cruise ships are proposing to do to be
able to get folks safely home you know
obviously you know there's no easy
solution to this you know you could just
leave them on the ship for forever that
that's obviously not something they want
to do
you can't just release them you know
into the general public if they've been
exposed so they're trying to figure out
a way where they can be safely
transported to their country of origin
without having interactions or contacts
with the general public either in
Florida or anywhere I think so I think
that's details in the case of in the
case of the Rotterdam 311 of them are
American citizens 52 of them are
Floridians yeah so we're we're obviously
working on a plan I've authorized the
National Guard to support logistics
operations as necessary to be able to
help repatriate the Florida citizens so
it's got to be done carefully it's got
to be done with safety in mind
but I think that's probably you know the
best way to go about it I mean obviously
as governor I have an interest in
getting Floridians back to Florida
safely I also have an interest in making
sure that if a Floridian has been
exposed to this virus that they're not
in a position to expose others so all
those things are being worked on but
it's it's going to be done carefully and
I think that that's really the
appropriate way to do it you know at the
end of the day you know these cruise
ships
you know our problems when you talk
about a respiratory contagious virus and
so I know that they've stopped sailing
you still have some of the ones that had
been had taken off in March and and
that's just the situation we find
ourselves in I mean if I would like to
just snap my fingers and no one would be
on a cruise ship right now they'd all be
at home I would do that in a second but
that's just not the situation we find
ourselves in it's an incredibly
difficult situation we spoke to the son
a son yesterday who had parents on board
one of the cruise ships and said his
father couldn't get badly needed
medicine and when the doctor got to him
it was the hundred and sixty eighth
person he had seen that day so it's a
rough situation for a lot of those folks
bored final question to you governor the
New York Times this morning ran a
headline Florida on coronavirus lockdown
finally they were critical in saying
that you were far too late especially
with shutting down some of those beaches
looking back could you have done
anything differently well so we have
just so you know we have a majority of
our cases are in Southeast Florida
they've been under restricted measures
now you know miami-dade are number one
hot spot for a couple weeks so we just
approached it regionally because it's
not the same you know throughout the
state once they did the 30 day extension
you know we're in a situation the
countries hit the pause button and so
that's just the reality of the situation
and so even though I have parts of the
state where the infections are extremely
extremely low you know we felt it made
sense to go in this direction but that
was based on you know the data and the
facts that we had before us and so you
know it's been I've been a thoughtful
strategic approach based on the evidence
that we've had and I think Southeast
Florida you've seen aggressive measures
taken early and now statewide even in
areas where we may not have a very high
infection rate but I just think it's the
right thing to do at this point I'm
running out of time but do you feel like
you have the situation under control
there now well this is a this is a very
difficult situation I mean what we've
tried to do is expand testing so that we
have good data on what we're actually
doing and so we've ended up I think
we're over 80,000 tests now most of
those in the last three or four weeks so
once we hit a hundred thousand that'll
be one test for every 200 residents here
which is what South Korea did they were
viewed as the gold standard of testing
so we've made huge strides on that and I
think that as we get to that point you
know we're going to be able to really
have a handle on where this is spreading
where it may not be spreading as much
and then tailor policies going forward
to be able to address it but you know a
lot of the stuff two weeks ago you know
a lot of people were making decisions
without having any real facts we're
starting to get more facts in I think we
understand a little bit more I'm about
the virus and so we've tried to react
them accordingly but our testing you
know we have more negative results
than almost every almost any state I
think New York may have more tested so
much so we're gonna continue to test
test test because I think that's how you
know how to bat it we'd love to check
back in with you and get another update
on these cruise ships as they come in
Governor appreciate you coming on the
program today obviously your population
so many of them over the age of 65 it's
a it's a gonna be a huge challenge going
forward appreciate it governor thank you
Thanks